[Musik]
Null an Schlafen wer ist denn noch hier
drauf
wir sind zu dritt Hacker aber ihr kennt
doch die alpine ich kann ich in die
Nitrado Server Konsole gehen denn dann
irgendwie in der Benutzerverwaltung das
irgendwie machen
ja
da mache ich es darüber einfach sicher
ja Lukas kein Server Operator mehr
Sandra bin ich kein Operator mehr weil
bei mir steht das nicht im Chat wo steht
da wo stand das denn
so ganz kurz Leute prank mich Sandra
gerade wirklich weil wenn Sandra mir
jetzt auch noch vorgeht dass ich kein
Operator mehr bin Luca ich schwöre dir
ich habe keine Ahnung wie man das macht
ich wollte heute nicht mal Minecraft
zocken geh runter vom Server das geht
nicht ich glaube wir werden gerade
gehackt weil ich wollte gerade in
Nitrado reingehen das ging nicht wenn
ich jetzt nicht mehr Operator bin hat er
mir sogar noch die rechte weggenommen
der hat irgendwie Zugriff auf unseren
Nitrado glaube ich also Sandra
schwörsdorf wird kein prank ist von dir
ich schwöre aus Svetlana so war ich hier
ich habe nichts gemacht
hat dir zu du bist der nächste wie ich
bin der nächste hätte ich noch nicht im
Stream gesagt dass ich in das Nitrado
Interface gehe hätte ich das mal nicht
gesagt
jetzt auf deine Eltern dass du es nicht
warst dicker nicht auf meine Eltern weil
stell dir mal vor nein ich habe aus
Versehen das ist jetzt irgendwie Malik
oder so weil er noch in Zukunft auf dem
PC hat oder was weiß ich nein das geht
gar nicht ich der hat doch der hat nicht
mal Laptop
dann kann er auf den Server er kann nein
er kann nach Hause hol mal ich jetzt vor
den vor dem vor dem Monitor einmal kurz
ist ja noch wach Mark ich bin bei
Michelle zu Hause
das schon ziemlich saß gerade Ruf Malik
an 2 %. diese zwei Prozent ist
eigentlich dafür dass meine Mutter mich
gleich abholt ne ey okay Sandy dann ist
es ein prank von dir wenn du jetzt schon
sagst ja ich sage mal ich sag hol mal
wenn du sagst nicht ich bin mit Michelle
ich sage okay dann ruf ihn ich habe 2%
du hast vor zwei Stunden schon 2%
ja aber dann hat doch dein Handy ich
habe dir keine Lust habe wie wichtig ist
dir der Server hey Sandra
ich glaube einfach mein Bruder schreibt
äh nein warum die Sache ist ich kann
jetzt ja nicht mal die Welt sichern weil
ich ja nicht in Server Interface
reinkomme wie wichtig ja in Geld oder
wie jetzt rein und wir kämpfen wir
können nicht gegen ihn gewinnen der
Fluss hat mir zu du hast keinen Backup
mehr und die Datei würde ich nicht
aufspielen
[Musik]
hey Sandra ich schreibe ich schreibe dir
bei Whatsapp ich schreibe dir bei
Whatsapp das sieht er nicht der kann ja
Stream sehen der kann ja alles sehen was
wir hier zeigen was wir sagen aber wenn
ich jetzt schreibe Folgen Zugriff auf
deinen PC ja Bro das ist jetzt Cap ich
habe schreibt er mit Handy zu WhatsApp
Web nein nein nein nein nein ich schreib
mein Handy oder hast du kein Zugriff
drauf wir holen jetzt Malik dazu über
Facebook
sein nein nein hört immer zu Malik alle
denken dass du das bist auf dem Server
aber das bist du doch nicht oder
Leute ist dicker der muss zur Schule
Luca wenn du es warst
kriege ich 1000 € von dir was hast du
gerade gesagt wenn ich das war kriegst
du 1000 €. ja okay in Ordnung wenn du es
warst krieg ich tausend Euro
. okay
[Musik]
deswegen habe ich jetzt gerade nicht
mehr so viel Angst weil dann hätte er
uns getötet ihm geht es nicht darum zu
töten
einfach nur darum
was willst du von mir oh mein Gott oh
mein Gott ey wenn der das anzündet ist
ja alles weg
was willst du was willst du was willst
du was ist ein Trottel dicker Malik
das ist nicht Malik
sondern man
Digger wie denn
[Musik]
Pferd nein der hatte nein Ferdinand hey
Luca das mit mir zu gruselig bin
rausfinden wer das ist der muss uns
jetzt mal dann lass uns Ultimatum setzen
no joke sagt
mal bitte einfach was du willst
[Musik]
sehen
safe prank sowieso weil sonst hätte ihn
schon längst gekillt wie sollen wir ihn
killen wenn er den Creative Modus drin
hat und geben die nicht wegnehmen können
für uns an ich kann ihn nicht anmachen
weil er mir die op-rechte weggenommen
hat du hast doch gesehen er hat Zugriff
auf die Nitrado Server Konsole das ist
entweder das ist einer von Nitrado das
kann ich mir aber nicht vorstellen die
seriöses Unternehmen oder irgendjemand
[Musik]
1000 hat er gerade geschrieben
die machen eh einen neuen Server
[Musik]
es ist jetzt nicht wahr ich kann nicht
mehr was ist das 1.000 Euro oder ich
komme immer wieder okay dann spielen wir
ab jetzt kein mein Minecraft mehr ja ich
schreibe mit Polizei ist nicht witzig
schalte die Polizei ein machen einfach
wir probieren mit hahaha
die Polizei machen einfach einen neuen
Server schaltet sie ein der meistens
haben so Hecke halten Null Angst vor der
Polizei ne bin mit VPN da kommt nichts
rum ja das ist das meinte ich schon also
Hacker Sachen mit Polizei da kommt nie
was ja ich will jetzt auch nicht noch
eine Nacht abwarten ne wir müssen jetzt
eine Lösung finden innerhalb der
nächsten 3 Minuten sonst ist hier wieder
dunkel und der kommt wieder kennt ihr
Malik ja das ist mein Bruder jetzt sagt
nicht zu meinem Bruder ich schwöre wenn
die Polizei rufen direkt runter junge ja
aber ich will ja ich will ja wissen er
schreibt kennt ihr Malik das heißt es
muss ja irgendwie ein Kollege von Alex
sein oder so nein haben
ich bin es Sandra
Ruf nochmal Malik an wer ist das nicht
schick Malik auch immer solche komischen
Smileys gibt
der soll was sagen was normale
sagen kann was ist dein Geburtsort das
ist stark er antwortet nicht weil das
nicht weiß ja okay ich glaube wir
brauchen uns keine Gedanken machen auf
jeden Fall keine
Ahnung Bruder wie gesagt ich bin offline
ich kann das nicht mehr komm wir
schreiben noch eine letzte Nachricht an
ihn schreib du meine nette letzte
Nachricht und sag ihm mal weil
Freundlichkeit gewinnt immer wird keines
danke für die ganze Scheiße gerne
mit keines ja gut okay ich rufe die
Polizei jetzt gleich erstmal ja lass uns
gleich mal telefonieren okay Leute ich
gehe offline weil ich scheiß mal in die
Hose ciao ciao Handy ich mache mir da
jetzt keine großen Sorgen weil überlegt
mal so ich mache halt also dass er
irgendwas über WhatsApp eine
whatsapp-nachricht wusste dass es Zufall
gewesen das war Zufall das einzige was
halt wirklich sein kann ist dass es
entweder malig ist oder Sirio weil die
beiden die einzigen waren die mit auf
diesem Server drauf waren Siri und ich
hatten unseren Minecraft-Server vorher
als privaten Server weil wir dort ein
bisschen gezockt haben und Malik hat
halt die einlogdaten noch weil er damals
ja da ich dann noch konserie und nicht
selfie Sandra 99 es muss Siri oder Malik
sein im nächsten Stream seht ihr auf
jeden Fall Bescheid im nächsten Stream
checkt es dann hoffentlich oder finden
wir es raus im besten Fall kommt er
einfach nicht mehr wieder
prank kommt beim nächsten Mal
[Musik]